THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: WELL, EXPRESS
ANYTHING E ANY DISSENT FROM
THE PREVAIL FAIR TRADE
COFFEE SHOP VIEW ON THE
TELEVISION AND THE LEFT WILL
TRY TO SHUT YOU DOWN.
TRUST ME WE HAVE LIVED THAT.
IF YOU DO IT IN REAL LIFE
THEY MAY PHYSICALLY ATTACK
YOU AND CALL THEMSELVES
VICTIMS.
HAYDEN WILLIAMS LEARNED THAT
LESSON THE HARDWAY LAST
MONTH.
HE WAS ATTACKED WHILE TRYING
TO RECRUIT CONSERVATIVES AT
UC BERKELEY YESTERDAY
APPARENT ATTACKER ZACHERY
GREENBERG PLEADED NOT GUILTY
TO THREE FELONIES IN THE
INCIDENT.
LARRY ELDER IS A LONG-TIME
CALIFORNIAN ONE OF THE
SMARTEST AND RADIO SHOW HOST
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
MY FIRST THOUGHT SINCE HAVE
YOU BEEN THERE I THINK YOUR
WHOLE LIFE, COULD YOU WEAR A
DONALD TRUMP HAT OR SHIRT
AND WALK INTO GRIFFITH PARK
IN LOS ANGELES?
HOW WOULD YOU DO THAT?
>> IT WOULDN’T BE ADVISABLE.
I LIVE ON THE WEST SIDE OF
LOS ANGELES AND I WOULDN’T
THINK ABOUT WEARING A MAGA
CAP TO ANYWHERE LIKE SANTA
MONICA.
YOU ARE LITERALLY ASKING FOR
SOMEBODY TO HIT YOU IN THE
FACE.
IT’S NOT JUST ABOUT HATS.
IT’S ABOUT BUMPER STICKERS
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION PUT
A DONALD TRUMP BUMPER
STICKER ON YOUR CAR AND
DRIVE IT SOMEWHERE ON THE
WEST SIDE AND PARK IT AND
LEAF IT FOR A FEW HOURS COME
BACK AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I HAD A SHOW WHERE I ASKED
PEOPLE TO CALL IN AND ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT YOUR CAR HAD
BEEN DEFACED AND WHETHER YOU
HAD A HILLARY OR TRUMP
STICKER.
EVERYBODY WHO CALLED UP WHO
MADE A COMPLAINT HAD A TRUMP
STICKER.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON WHO HAD
A HILLARY STICKER REPORTED
THAT HE OR SHE HAD HIS OR
HER CAR DEFACED.
IT’S A SERIOUS KIND OF
THING.
THESE PEOPLE BELIEVE THE
OTHER SIDE, TUCKER, IS NOT
JUST WRONG.
THEY BELIEVE THE OTHER SIDE
IS BAD, IS EVIL.
THAT WAY THEY CAN JUSTIFY
TAKING THESE KINDS OF
PHYSICAL ACTIONS.
THE GOOD NEWS THOUGH ABOUT
THE UC BERKELEY THING IS THE
GUY WHO DID THE ASSAULT, THE
PEPPER TURNED OUT NOT TO BE
A STUDENT THE UC BERKELEY
ASSISTED IN GETTING THE GUY
ARRESTED.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR THEM.
SINCE CLEARLY WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A MOMENT BUT
MOMENTS CHANGE, WE ARE IN A
MOMENT WHERE ONE SIDE IS NOT
ALLOWED TO EXPRESS ITS
POLITICAL VIEWS IN PUBLIC
FOR FEAR OF FACING VIOLENCE
AT LEAST IN LIBERAL CITIES
YOU HAVE.
HEARD LIBERALS SAY WAIT A
SECOND MAYBE IF WE ARE
PUNCHING TRUMP SUPPORTER
WILL ANYBODY PUNCH US?
HAS ANYBODY SAID THIS IS A
BAD IDEA.
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
TRUMP GOT ELECTED IN
NOVEMBER OF 2016.
THE ACADEMIA AROUND THIS
COUNTRY WENT ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY A PROFESSOR WHO
LIKENED TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO
TERRORISTS.
IT’S INSANE.
AND YOU LOOK AT THE
IMBALANCE IN TERMS OF
REGISTRATION WHERE WEATHER
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN YOU
ARE LOOKING AT DEPARTMENTS
OF POLYCY WHERE 20 OR 30
PROFESSORS THERE ONE MIGHT
BE REGISTER YOU HAD AS A
REPUBLICAN.
NO NO SOCIALIST REGISTERED
AS A REPUBLICAN.
NOBODY IN WOMEN’S STUDIES
REGISTERED AS A REPUBLICAN.
ASSUMING HAS IMPACT ON
THOUGHT AND REACH YOU HAVE
TO CONCLUDE THE MORE LIKELY
YOU GO TO COLLEGE IF YOU
MEASURE IN HUMANITIES, MOST
PEOPLE DO THE MORE LIKELY
YOU WILL COME OUT LEFT WING
THAT’S WHY TUCKER THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO GIVE YOU
TELEVISION-FREE
TUITION-FREE COLLEGE IF YOU
WERE LIKELY BE COMING OUT
REPUBLICAN WE WOULDN’T HAVE
THIS EDUCATION?
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD YOU
EVER SEND A CHILD TO COLLEGE
I CURRENTLY AM.
IT KILLS ME.
AT ONE POINT IT’S POISONING
OUR KIDS ACTUALLY KILLING
SOME OF THEM.
KILLING THE COUNTRY WE ARE
OPTING OUT.
HOW FAR AWAY IS THAT POINT.
>> GOING TO TAKE THE ALUMNI
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
COLLEGES DEPEND ON
CONTRIBUTION FROM THE ALUMNI
WHEN THEY UNDERSTAND THEIR
KIDS ARE NOT GETTING AN
EDUCATION THEY ARE GETTING
INDOCTRINATION UNTIL THEN
NOTHING IS GOING TO CHANGE.
>> Tucker: NOT IMPRESSIVE